- [Instructor] Let's see if we can name
this guy right over here.
And so like always,
we always wanna look for
the longest carbon chain
or the longest carbon cycle,
and I think it's pretty
obvious from this picture
that we have a very long carbon cycle here
that we can start,
or we can just look at this.
We have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight carbons
in a cycle right over here,
and so we can call this backbone,
which is the backbone of our
molecule right over here,
this is cyclooctane.
Cyclooctane.
It's an octane in a cycle.
It's an alkane because
it's all single bonds
right over here,
so that is cyclooctane.
Now let's think about the different groups
that are attached to this
backbone right over here.
So first we can look at
this one right over here,
and we can ask ourselves,
well, how many carbons are there?
How many carbons?
Well, there's one, two, three,
four carbons that are
attached to the backbone.
So our prefix for when we're dealing
with four carbons is but-,
and it is in a cycle,
so this is a cyclobutyl group.
Cyclobutyl.
And we also have another
cyclobutyl right over here.
So this is another cyclobutyl.
Cyclobutyl.
Bu-, I'm misspelling it,
cyclobutyl group.
Now let's think about
this one right over here.
How many carbons are there?
We have one, two, three carbons.
So our prefix when we're dealing
with three carbons is prop-,
and they're in a cycle, as well,
so this is a cyclopropyl group.
Cyclopropyl.
This is a cyclopropyl group.
And now we can jump
over to these two groups
right over here.
We see that these are
clearly the same groups.
Let's count the number
of carbons they have.
We have one, two, three, four carbons.
So if we're dealing with four carbons,
we would think about the prefix but-,
but this isn't in a cycle
and it's not in just a straight chain.
It has this Y shape.
And so the common name when
we end up with this Y shape,
when we're attached
down here and then that,
we're attached to one carbon here
and that's attached to kind of this
carbon right over here
that's then attached to these other two,
this is a isobutyl group,
which we've seen multiple times before.
Isobutyl group.
And of course this one is
an isobutyl group, as well.
So these are both isobutyl groups.
Now the next thing we need to think about
is how we can number it.
We wanna go back to our main carbon chain,
which in this case is a cycle,
and think about how we wanna number.
And the convention is to start numbering
at the thing that is first
in alphabetical order.
And when we're considering
alphabetical order,
we think even the C in cyclo
and we think of the I in isobutyl.
If this was tert- or sec-,
you wouldn't think about the T or the S
in secbutyl or tertbutyl,
but for isobutyl,
you do consider the I.
For the cyclos, you consider the C.
And so when you look at it that way,
all of the Cs come before the Is,
and then amongst the Cs,
these all have cyclos,
but the cyclobutyl comes before
cyclopropyl or cyclooctane.
B comes before P or O.
So the thing that is first
alphabetically are both of these,
both of these cyclobutyls.
So we can start numbering
at where either of them attach
to the main carbon backbone.
But we have to,
or those are,
I guess we should say
those are both options,
but we wanna number from the one
that is gonna give us the
total lowest numbering.
So let's think about that a little bit.
So we could say, let's number from here.
Let's make this the one carbon.
And so that we hit something
else as soon as possible,
'cause remember we're trying
to minimize the numbers here,
we might wanna go clockwise,
so we hit a two right over here,
three, four, five, six, seven.
So in this situation,
where do we hit interesting things?
We hit interesting things
at the one, at the two,
or where do we have groups
attached to the chain?
One, two, four,
six and seven.
So that's one option.
We'll have things at groups
attached at one, two, four, six,
and seven if we start right over there
and if we were to go clockwise.
Our other option,
one, two, four, six, seven.
Our other option is to start,
and let me erase those.
Our other option is to start
at this other cyclobutyl,
this other cyclobutyl
group here on the left.
Let me erase these so I don't
mess up the diagram too much.
The other option is to start here,
make this the one,
number this as one,
and then we would also go clockwise
to hit the cyclopropyl as soon as quick,
to hit something else as soon as possible.
So two, three, four, five, six, seven.
So now where are we
hitting interesting things?
We have groups at the one
carbon, the two carbon,
the four carbon, the five carbon,
and the seven carbon.
So actually, this second
numbering is preferable.
Both of them have something
at the one, the two,
the four, and the seven,
but the second one has something at a five
while the first one
had something at a six.
So we would actually want to do
this numbering right over here,
and this is the numbering
that we now have on our,
that we have now listed right over here.
Let's now write what the name
of this molecule actually is.
So once again,
we start first in alphabetical order.
So we're gonna start with
the cyclobutyl groups,
and we have two of them,
one at the one carbon
and one at the four carbon.
So we could say one comma four,
and since there are two cyclobutyl groups,
we would say dicyclobutyl.
1,4-Dicyclobutyl.
And then what comes next
in alphabetical order
is the cyclopropyl.
That comes before isobutyl.
C comes before I.
That's at the two carbon.
So then we can say 2-cyclopropyl.
And now we can get to the two isobutyls,
so there's an isobutyl at the five carbon
and at the seven carbon.
So we can say five, seven,
and since there's two of them,
we'd say diisobutyl.
5,7-diisobutyl.
So diisobutyl.
And then we just give
the name of the backbone.
We've tackled, we've done the butyls,
the dicyclobutyls right there,
the cyclopropyl,
the two isobutyls,
and now we just write cyclooctane.
Cyclooctane.
And we are done.
We have successfully named the molecule.
And this was kind of fun.
It's like a secret code or something.
Now you wouldn't expect naming
organic molecules to be,
I think, quite so satisfying, but it is.